Hello Freak bitches.
That tank,
um,
is also something that helps you,
and this is where the connection to this journal comes from.
Juan,
you were going through this breakup,
you'd kind of reassessed your whole life.
It was really interesting to watch.
You know,
you,
you came when you called me up and you were really bummed out and she kicked you
out and you were at a hotel room.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
Hey,
you fucking come live with me.
And then you moved and you were like,
just a little frazzled.
You were like,
yeah,
thanks a lot man.
I really appreciate it.
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm living by myself.
This is all good.
You know,
Dunkin's live with me now.
We're going to have some fun.
It's been the only dude.
Everything's gonna be fine.
But you were clearly like lost,
you know,
you'd,
you'd like gotten,
you know,
when you get dumped man,
it's like just fucking feeling of shit.
I don't have a home anymore.
Like,
where am I sleeping now?
Civ like,
just,
uh,
towards your direction,
change complete.
You've been living this certain way along enough to,
to get used to it and then all of a sudden everything absolutely changes,
like just a huge torque turn that you probably thought could happen.
But you're,
you know,
trying to imagine that it wasn't even a possibility and it happens.
Well that,
yeah,
that's like you go into shock,
you're attached to a certain rhythm,
a certain pattern,
a certain set of surroundings that massively changes you.
You go into shock and that is the perfect time to get in a fucking flotation
tank when everything's discombobulated and floating around inside of you and all
the other,
uh,
weird assemblage of emotions.
And more than anything though,
what's cool about that shit is you get a real taste of truth.
Like that's what truth is right there.
That's like the experience of truth,
which is change,
which is dramatic.
Radical change.
Fucking unavoidable happens all the time.
Did the,
the isolation tank keeps you from distracting yourself and makes you think about
your life?
Yeah.
It makes you think about what's going on.
So for me it was so fascinating having you here at a real low point.
And watching you pull right out of it right out of it,
like very quickly,
like,
well,
you got into that tank within a few weeks,
man,
you were laughing about shit and joking around about it.
Sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
They always cool.
It was,
yeah,
it definitely,
definitely helps.
And that's why this is my friends are so important because like if you don't
have friends and you get into that predicament oh,
terrible.
So worst feeling more it feel completely alone.
Yeah.
And,
but you know,
even if you don't have friends,
you can still pull yourself out of it,
but you have to,
I guess really Wa you know,
you,
you have to want to,
yeah,
yeah.
You,
well,
it's,
it's mean,
look,
anyone can can improve their surroundings so you can improve your situation.
But it was really interesting for me watching you because it was a such an
unusual opportunity for both of us.
It was an unusual opportunity for me to watch someone who didn't have a lot of
experience with a tank,
but who was such a curious person and psychedelically experience like you and
then have access to this thing a on a daily basis,
you know?
And for me to watch you go from this like really low point to like,
they're like really like gaining ground.
Like you came out of it like stronger.
It was so fucking cool
climbing out of that thing in that state of being in the,
in the state of like having had,
because you know,
so I could,
psychedelics are not limited it drugs.
There are many ways to induce a psychedelic state of mind.
The tank being one of them.
And um,
another way to induce a psychedelic state of mine is to have dramatic change
happened in your life that rips back whatever delusion you are living by and
shows you
the true universe.
Yeah.
People turn to the term psychedelic to a lot of people means like seeing things
that aren't their hallucinations,
dancing mice,
you know,
Shit like that.
Pink elephants flying in the sky.
That's not a real psychedelic state.
The real psychedelic state is the dissolution of cultural conformity and the,
the Ah,
your ideas of the universe,
all your predetermined patterns of thinking all your,
you're adopted behavior patterns,
all that gets stripped away and you're left with the core of you and your
decisions and,
and what,
what you can and can't change.
And how you led yourself into a position where you were so weak in the first
place that you,
you know,
you needed saving from.
Like what,
what were,
why did you have no foundation?
Why did you fall apart?
Like what is it about,
you know,
life and about trying to get by in this world that leaves us so fucking
vulnerable sometimes and so in need of other human beings is to to stack us up
and to hold us up and watching you man was really fucking cool.
It was really cool because you really used it,
man.
You got in there all the time,
you know,
and you are,
you are getting out and talking about it.
And it was,
it was fucking trip.
You know,
I don't know if you wrote it about it in the thing because I didn't read it.
I,
I've had that thing for years that they didn't even take a look at that.
I read to him over the phone and then he made me stop and I said,
all right,
I won't read any more of it.
I was just eight years ago,
I got a thing has been sitting in my fucking,
my office for tariff.
I think it's like 2004 so what year was this?
Wait til I didn't date it.
2004 or 2005 I believe it was.
Yeah.
It's cool though.
I mean you're,
you,
you got a window into a certain time in your life.
You know where you were.
You were in the shifts.
Well,
I'll tell you man,
that unfortunately happens.
But you know,
you say that,
but I don't think it's unfortunate at all.
Oh,
right.
If you were stuck with that chick now,
no,
Jesus Christ.
Think about that.
Thinking about your situation now and thinking about your situation then,
how much happier you are now,
right?
You could have been stuck.
Me Ma,
if you know,
if you talked her into taking you back or something gross.
Oh,
with a child or something.
Jesus Christ right there.
You know what I mean?
It's funny how you're a different human now then.
Yeah,
you're so much more confident.
You know?
It's one of the things that I saw when you went up in Montreal,
right?
I keeping your sats now you're so much more confident.
You go up there,
you're much more,
you know,
you're so much more,
what's the word you,
you,
you were re resigned to who?
You are not,
not resigned.
Rather you're,
you're not,
but it's not resigned that,
cause that sounds like you're giving up.
It's not,
that's not what I mean.
You're,
you are completely aware of who you are.
That's the best way of saying it.
And that when you're going on stage now you're going on stage,
not trying to convince them of anything.
You're just,
this is me and this is what I'm doing is what I have to say.
Whereas before you were like,
Hey,
I hope you like me.
Do you like me?
You don't like me?
Well,
here I'm going to say something,
I guess.
I guess that,
yeah,
I think the reason the word resigned popped out of your mouth first is because I
think there is a certain level of being,
and it sounds like it's like I'm giving up,
but resigned can also be like a kind of surrender where you're like,
I'm just no longer going to spend time,
whether on stage or off stage.
I'm not going to spend time anymore trying to convince myself or other people
that I'm some certain way and I'm going to start trying to approach people from
where I'm at.
Yes.
Which is,
which is not a perfect place for most people.
Most most of us are,
you know,
have fucked up things that we do.
And why wouldn't you?
I mean,
you're going to look at where you're at.
Like you say,
we're in a fucking ball flying through fucking space.
How are you supposed to adapt to this?
And some brilliant way,
right off the bat,
you know you,
yeah,
it's a champ.
You're in this insane dimension where were getting rocketed through space where
you're to die.
You're surrounded by people who call themselves your family that you're supposed
to have attachments to,
they're going to die.
You're in a life where you've just adopted certain modes of being.
I didn't have a baby,
I didn't get married,
but a lot of people do when they weren't ready and they weren't supposed to and
they get married and they have a baby and they are theoretically for this
incarnation,
pretty fucking trapped there in
lot of people are,
a lot of people have yet they have all kinds of weird situations where the
relationship,
they're stuck somehow or another,
whether it's because of a mortgage or because of a business that they started
together,
a mental idea of how things are supposed to do with some person or you give
birth to a child that has like a a melted brain and you've got to take care of
like a little like sick kid for 12 years or like there's so many different ways
that your particular DNA can get reverberated down into a shitty trap where
you're just like there.
It's like a,
that's why I liked that movie.
You said you didn't want to see it and I'm sorry if you've seen it in like it,
but what was that hundred and 27 hours?
Did you see that?
No,
I didn't see it because I knew the story and I,
you know,
I don't want to wash them.
Did
happen.
That's just a torture movie.
There's no reason to watch.
Everybody says that it's a torture movie.
Like it was fixated on the Gore or the,
but it wasn't,
it's a fucking metaphor,
which is that,
uh,
some times doing the,
you love to do whatever it is and that's for a lot of people's fucking doing the
thing you love most,
you can end up getting your goddamn arm pen down.
You're connecting someone,
having a baby to cutting your arm off.
That's funny.
No,
I'm kidding.
I'm not connecting.
If you have a baby for the right reason.
No,
I know what you're saying for the wrong reasons.
I know,
I know what you're saying.
Like you were saying what a lot of single people with no children say.
And what you're saying is,
you know,
we were talking about our friend who tweeted something about having a child is
like the exact opposite of winning the lottery.
Yeah.
I used to think the exact same way until I had children,
but my situation is very different in that,
first of all,
I'm older,
I've had more experience in life and um,
I'm secure financially and happy in the relationship.
So it was all good things at a good time.
But when I look back on past relationships,
some of them,
there was a bunch of relationships that I've been in,
you know,
like way back in the day when I was younger and I really didn't know what the
fuck I was doing and I was hanging around with chicks that I probably really
didn't even like that much,
but I was still having sex with them.
And sometimes you'd have like a crazy fucking breakup or we're crazy bad
relationship.
That person could be out there with your kid and then you have to deal with all
kinds of the nonsense that comes with that.
I mean,
we all know somebody that has kids.
You know some shit situation.
So I,
I hear what you're saying man.
What did that so what yeah,
what I'm really saying is like the,
the idea and it goes back to what we're being comfortable resigned to who you
are.
That's where I didn't like the way I said resign though I didn't mean reside is
just sometimes you hard to be resigned.
You know what I mean?
Not all of us are fucking Charlie Sheen,
not all stars from Mars.
Not all of us,
sort of a freaking rock star from Mars.
Some of us are like,
we all are trying to pretend that I'm not special or fucked up.
And a lot of ways man,
and,
and that's,
if you start from,
it's like,
you know,
one thing that I would try to do,
and I used to work out and it's like when I,
when I,
when I first started working out,
I would try to lift weight that was so much more heavy than what I should have
been lifting out of this sense of like I could lift heavy weights.
And so now I'm like trying to live like way too well.
I don't like why should it be at the fucking pink weights?
And I'm like trying to take a quick,
you know what I mean?
I'm trying to do like really fucking heavy weights cause it's like this is how I
see myself down the line after I've been lifting pink waits for awhile.
That's how you get to the heavyweights.
But if you start off right away trying to pump those fucking heavyweights,
then it's disaster.
You're going to pull your fucking muscles like people how,
you know like due to lifting weights.
One guy think came up to me,
he's like looking at me like what are you doing?
He's like that's way too much weight.
And so this is like having a kid when you're 16 having a kid when you were 16 or
deciding that you're a famous comedian before you are getting on stage after a
couple of months and getting in your fucking head that you're like you've been
doing standup for 15 years or being a fucking when and like just immediately
thinking you're a great painter.
Cause I've had friends who've gotten into painting,
right?
And they've only painted for a year and they show me some of their paintings and
the look on their face is like,
I'm supposed to react to it.
Like I'm seeing a Picasso or something.
It's like I hate
almost everyone that shows me things that I'm supposed to look at that they did
almost every time someone does that to me.
I'm like,
are you really going to do this to me man,
I'm these.
No,
don't make me read your fucking script.
Don't ask me to read your script.
You fuck take you read my script row.
It's the worst.
The worst is when it's bad.
And then you're obligated to talk to them and go,
all right,
here's the situation.
You know,
you basically did men and black meets back to the future written by a 12 year
old.
You know,
like,
it's like,
I can't say that.
We can't even say that.
You have to go,
well,
I'm as pretty good man.
It's pretty good.
Well now then you're gonna see that's the thing.
That's where you get and I think kind of what we're talking about,
which is like at some point you have to make a decision.
Am I going to spend the rest of my life lying to the world?
Am I going to spend the rest of my life men trying to manipulate people around
me because I'm too lazy to tell them the truth or am I just going to start
telling the truth?
But what if it though,
if it's a friend that's written something really cool though,
what if someone has got a script and it means,
so that's the problem with all the shitheads that want you to read their scripts
and makes you super skeptical for the occasional rare person that actually write
something good and it's just like,
Hey,
I think this is pretty good.
You want to read it and then you're like,
Eh,
all right,
I'll read it.
You know what I mean?
How many,
how many of those are there?
People I know who are really good at things,
they don't ask me to look at it.
I ended up looking at it cause I want to like my friend email,
he just visited like his music's fucking good.
So like I tried to get new cds of his,
cause I wanna listen to it.
That's really fucking good.
But sometimes somebody else sends you something
or somebody be in their car if they're a musician and then they'll put their
shit,
don't have to listen to it.
That is never let a musician drive and never let them get in your car with a CD.
It's in your hand,
your fucking hand,
because you're suddenly,
you're forced suddenly not just to evaluate how miserable and artists they are,
how close Shane shitty their music is.
But also you have to,
you realize that the fact that they felt comfortable playing this for you means
they think it's good.
So they,
they're so diluted and sell.
Fuck that.
They're like,
oh yeah,
I'm going to,
I,
they've been waiting all day to play their music.